tres actores claves reunidos en un
momento crucial el martes comenzaron las
conversaciones en teherán entre los
presidentes de turquía irán y rusia una
continuación del proceso de astaná de
2017 con la prioridad de encontrar una
solución pacífica en siria
la cuestión del retorno de los
refugiados sirios a sus hogares y
ciudades la cuestión de ayudar a la paz
la estabilidad y la seguridad en siria
están en la agenda de esta reunión
trilateral
pero aunque la paz ocupa un lugar
destacado es la guerra en ucrania la que
probablemente ocupe el centro del
escenario turquía busca la luz verde
para lanzar una nueva operación militar
en el norte de siria precisamente contra
las localidades de tal rifat imán vieja
las dos ciudades están bajo el control
de la milicia kurda del gpg acusada por
ankara de estar vinculada al partido de
los trabajadores del kurdistán y
clasificadas como terroristas por las
autoridades turcas el objetivo del
presidente está allí verdad es ahora
establecer una zona de seguridad de 30
kilómetros en la frontera turco siria
pero moscú se ha opuesto a cualquier
otra ofensiva el tema ucrania también va
a ocupar un lugar destacado entre los
presidentes turco y ruso en particular
un acuerdo que permita la exportación de
20 millones de toneladas de grano
ucraniano a través del mar negro en
coordinación con las naciones unidas-
ankara se ha posicionado como mediador
entre moscú y kiev con quien aún
mantiene buenas relaciones mientras
tanto irán intenta aprovechar las
conversaciones para aprobar nuevos
contratos de armas con rusia al tiempo
que impulsa los lazos mutuos para eludir
las más recientes sanciones económicas
que afectan a ambos países
para vladimir putin la cumbre sobre todo
un mensaje político occidente un
recordatorio de que aún cuenta con el
apoyo de muchas potencias mundiales en
medio de la invasión de su país a
ucrania